ولكن الصوره هناك انت كنت شبب دو شوف هذه
الصوره نعم صحيح صحيح
يعني انتم طبعا
تتجاوروا بالحياه بالشغل بالكتابه نعم كيف
قادرين تحملوا بعض صح ههه
محمود درويش رحمه الله قال دائما كان
يداعبنا عندما يكون معنا هنا في الرباط
يقول لي يا حسن كيف تتحمل
نفس المراه يا اخي 30 سنه كم 30 استنى
معقول يا اخي طلقها خلاص طلقها طلقت كله
حرام عليك يا محمود حرام يعني
خلاص
سيدتي خلاص
عائشه طبعا رحله عمر اااه
التقينا اولا كثير الميدين في الاعدادي في
الكوليج
في نهايه الاعدادي كانت هي تلميذه نجيبه
عند نفس الاستاذ الذي يدرسني استاذ احمد
دب كان استاذا للغه العربيه عظيمه من شمال
المغرب
سلوك انه اخلاق انواع
مهنيته
في هذه
فكان ياتي الى القسم اللي انا فيه رقم
اثنين ويحكي ويحكي لنا عن تلميذه له
مجتهده واسعه الافاق الى اخره
وياتي عندهم في قسم مخصص للبنات
وبدات
العلاقات
16 سنه
76 عن نجيب محفوظ تحدثنا عن كتابته
ولحظات التي تميز تحولات اسلوب كتابه
وفي محفظتي رساله اليها وهي ايضا رساله
الامس تحميل الجواب عنها في رسالته فانا
واحنا اتلاميس صغار
لينا عندها ماستر الان في العلوم السياسيه
والاجتماعيه في برلين ايضا هي في برلين
والبنت صغيره شامه عندها الاجازه الان في
في البيولوجيا